tierras resecas ganado escuálido el
cuerno de áfrica está sumido en una
sequía paralizante agravada por el
cambio climático ya ha pasado casi un
mes del teórico inicio de la temporada
de lluvias en la región pero aún no ha
empezado lo que está poniendo a millones
de personas en riesgo de hambruna after
free file brain in 6 jones después de
tres temporadas de lluvias fallidas se
estima que la región es la más seca de
los últimos 40 años ahora estamos
esperando que llegue la actual temporada
de lluvias llega tarde y nos preocupa
mucho cuáles serán las implicaciones si
está por debajo de la media de cayón
sobre
todo a rich el programa mundial de
alimentos afirma que el número de
personas que pasan hambre a causa de la
sequía podría pasar de los 14 millones
actuales a más de 20 millones la guerra
en ucrania que ha disparado los precios
de los alimentos y el combustible ha
agravado la situación para los países
que dependen de las exportaciones de
trigo del mar negro el coste de la cesta
de alimentos ya ha aumentado
en etiopía creció un 66 por ciento
mientras que en somalia lo ha hecho un
36% los índices de malnutrición se
disparan en etiopía después de que unas
inundaciones provocarán la pérdida de
las cosechas y la muerte de más de un
millón de cabezas de ganado
la sequía y las inundaciones nos
devastaron no pudimos con los daños ya
que se produjeron de forma consecutiva
primero se inundaron todas las tierras
luego la sequía causa aún más daños y
agravó a nuestros problemas en somalia
se calcula que 1,4 millones de niños
menores de 5 años sufrirán desnutrición
aguda este año las agencias de ayuda
advierten de un gran déficit de
financiación para hacer frente a la
crisis aseguran que se está acabando el
tiempo para evitar un desastre
humanitario
catastrófico